herbstspaziergang in berlin
für läufer muslim und ihren mann war das
vor zwei monaten noch völlig undenkbar
die beiden syrer sind vor dem
bürgerkrieg in ihrer heimatstadt kubaner
geflüchtet sie kamen mit dem boot über
das mittelmeer
einzig ihre smartphones gaben ihnen
orientierung
ich habe eine navigations app für boote
benutzt als ich mit vielen anderen das
mittelmeer von der türkischen westküste
richtung griechenland durchquerte die
app zeigte unsere genaue position an und
auch andere schiffe in der nähe falls
unser boot sinken würde
auf der flucht wurde das ehepaar
auseinandergerissen
der syrische komponist gelangte nach
einem monat als erster nach deutschland
nur über sein smartphone konnte er den
kontakt zu seiner frau halten
ich habe meine koordinaten über das
smartphone geschickt per whatsapp das
verbraucht nicht viel datenvolumen
fascher hat mir dann mögliche fluchtwege
rausgesucht orientierungshilfe in berlin
gibt den beiden die facebook-gruppe das
syrische haus in deutschland die
überwiegend arabischsprachige seite hat
rund 96.000 fans gegründet wurde sie von
dem syrischen blogger moniz buchari
am missouri geschaut und nur wenige
flüchtlinge fühlen sich fremd in
deutschland und sie haben große
zukunftsängste über unsere gruppe können
sie kontakt zu anderen syrern aufnehmen
die schon länger hier sind die können
ihre ängste und probleme am besten
nachempfinden und ihnen ein wenig
sicherheit vermitteln so spüren die
neuankömmlinge dass sie hier nicht
alleine sind
täglich erhält moniz bukhari hunderte
von fragen zu unterschiedlichen themen
beispielsweise zum deutschen
asylverfahren
inzwischen ist auch die deutsche
bundesregierung auf die facebook gruppe
aufmerksam geworden auf der plattform
will sie mehr über die bedürfnisse der
flüchtlinge erfahren der refugee hecke
ton in berlin
bei diesem dreitägigen workshop arbeiten
250 programmierer ehrenamtlich an apps
und webseiten
18 projekte wurden bisher entwickelt
darunter die plattform home for refugees
eine digitale wohnungsvermittlung für
flüchtlinge oder die app germany sail
world.com
eine übersicht über die wichtigsten
deutschen behörden die
internet-aktivisten anke domscheit berg
hat den digitalen freiwilligen workshop
organisiert
sie will barrieren zwischen flüchtlingen
und einheimischen abbauen
wir arbeiten zb daran wie man eine
engere soziale vernetzung zwischen
einheimischen und neuankömmlingen
erreichen kann dass man also nicht nur
sich zum beispiel gegenseitig eine
sprache beibringen sondern auch zusammen
gemeinsame hobbys verfolgt und
festgestellt dass man in gleichen
berufen arbeitet und da eben auch diese
art kontakte sich entwickeln auch lava
und basha moslem wollen schnellstmöglich
in der deutschen gesellschaft ankommen
die syrische sängerin weiß sie muss den
start in ihr neues leben selbst in die
hand nehmen
wir nutzen sprach apps auf unseren
smartphones
so können wir hoffentlich schnell
deutsch lernen mit hilfe der neuen
sprachkenntnisse wollen die beiden sich
möglichst schnell weiterbilden und
vielleicht mit ihren gemeinsam
komponierten liedern irgendwann
auftreten